i want to bring you some breaking news
from a sage briefing list of government
scientists this afternoon who say that
further restrictions are needed
within days to stop hospitals being
overwhelmed by the omicron surge sky
news understands that experts who
produce advice for ministers believe
there are hundreds of thousands of
infections every day many more than the
official number of cases recorded on the
daily dashboard the official figures
today say that there are 25 000 omicron
cases recorded in the uk and that is a
24-hour jump of some at 10 000. the
scientists go on to say that even if
transmission of the variant did stop now
a significant number of hospital
admissions are already
baked in
estimates
the case is likely to peak in january
these hospital admissions at well over 3
000 every day even with the current plan
b restrictions in england the scientists
say a return to measures we were living
with in april will be needed to stop
hospitals being overwhelmed that is
effectively step two restrictions of the
roadmap out of lockdown where pubs and
restaurants in england could only serve
at tables outside with indoor mixing
with other households
bands uh we're told the circuit breaker
would need to last for long enough for
everyone uh to get a booster building an
extra wall of uh defense so that is uh
what sky news understands has come out
of a sage briefing this afternoon so
clear concern about the omicron variant
and a suggestion that further
restrictions
certainly as far as england are
concerned are needed within days rather
than
after christmas to stop hospitals being
overwhelmed by the surge of omicron